BTW as mania at the AMAs plus what you
didn't see on TV from music's biggest
stars everybody hope you guys had a
great weekend but I guarantee was not as
amazing as the night BTS had at the
American Music Awards the International
superstars have completely won our
hearts over and the proof is in the fact
that we have been following their every
single move literally since they landed
at the airport
to the rehearsals and even last night
when they made history as the first
Korean group to perform at the AMAs they
even had Ansel Elgort fanboying out in
the crowd recording the performance on
his phone they really have just cast a
spell on the world and it's amazing to
see he was with the voice backstage just
after their electrifying performance
we don't game
[Applause]
you guys counted the choreography you
guys made history tonight at the AMAs
how do you feel yeah it was wonderful
what was it like to be on the AMA stage
um you know it's like there were like
millions of people standing and fans
were screaming and you know like oh you
know that world celebrate is in front of
us
still I cannot maybe I think we cannot
forget it like for a life lifelong if a
lifelong pisser as if that wasn't enough
of a moment for BTS during my interview
with them they said they were big fans
of zet while Zed caught wind of that
shortly after and tweeted the guys about
a collaboration now of course we caught
up with Zedd at the AMAs and he said
working with them would be an honor I
have some very very big news to break to
you right now I was just with BTS and I
know that you had said you'd love to
collaborate with them and I asked them
do you accept and they said yes they
would be honored to collaborate I would
be honored there before you I will see
them yeah is it about them I think
there's something about them being
themselves and a little bit geeky and I
think people like people who are natural
and it just seems like they're being
themselves and I love that they're right
said they're so genuine I'm legitimately
a BTS stand now guys you've changed me
all right it was a big night for those
boys but pink not only gave them a run
for their money she flew away from it
pink stole the show with the most
incredible death-defying high-flying
performance ever dancing on the side of
a hotel high-rise
[Music]
et has learned the performance was
actually pre-taped on Friday due to the
complicated technical requirements it
took pink five days of rehearsal to nail
the routine and she says it was
ultimately the scariest thing she has
ever done
now speaking of scary it has got to be
daunting to seeing a Whitney Houston
song let alone the greatest hits from
the bodyguard soundtrack the Christina
Aguilera took it to task performing a
tribute to her childhood idol now the
reactions were mixed and Twitter accused
pink of scowly during her performance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'll go game but pink says there
was no shadiness people she tweeted
quote I am in awe of Christina's talent
show the clip where I'm in tears you
have negative nancies
love that all right meanwhile Selena
Gomez delivered such a haunting
performance of wolves it was her first
time taking the stage since we're
covering from her kidney transplant
[Music]
[Music]
our eats he sources say she rehearse
like crazy to nail her comeback
performance and she dominated with that
new blonde dude did I see that I mean
check out this new hair with this dope
leather mini dress by coach she won the
best look of the night for me
Selena is back and clearly fresher than
ever all right but I want to know what
was your guys's favorite moment at last
night's AMAs there were a lot of big
moments which reminds me I got to give a
special shout-out to my fave Bruno Mars
who won Artist of the Year he couldn't
attend but watches Thank You speech
something like familiar I love you guys
more than anything I wish I could be
partying with y'all but I'm a million
miles away right now in a minivan please
forgive me I will be back and we'll be
jamming very shortly so cool I feel hot
like a dragon wanna retire man I'm too
hot okay guys I'll stop in other music
news a Forbes just released its list of
the highest-paid females and music and
should come as no surprise that beyonce
sits atop that list like the queen that
she is be made a whole lot of lemonade
thanks to her 2016 visual album pulling
a staggering 105 million dollars Forbes
reports she's followed by Adele to give
a swift Celine Dion and Jennifer Lopez
on that list so I guess it's true what
they say best revenge is your paper
alright guys thanks for watching today
let me tell you it's a short week
because of the Thanksgiving holiday but
we will be back tomorrow and Wednesday
with new videos so be sure to turn on
those notifications let's see you guys
then bye - ha
make a dragon wanna retire man I'm too
huh